the second geometry question now circle
geometry um sometimes we don't look at
this very much for the sake of your
extension one park please look at circle
geometry okay up not just like the hard
bit about this was not like ah
remembering which of the 20 properties
of a circle I'm supposed to use it was
seeing into the circle and understand
the geometry that was there there are
lots of lines and intervals and cords
flying around so people got confused
okay let's have a look at this the the
biggest problems throughout all these
parts were people admitting important
things from their reasoning here is the
first one if you have a circle just look
up at this okay if you have a circle
okay and you have a cord or if you like
you have an arc that corresponds through
that cord okay question here is an angle
here is another angle tell me which of
these angles has been substandard by
that cord on the circumference which of
the angles is it alpha or beta and the
answer is it's alpha and it's better
they're both subtended by the same cord
by the same arc and they're both on the
circumference but not not the same angle
are they what are they by the way what's
the relationship between these two
they're supplementary because they're
opposite angles in a cyclic quad they're
not equal unless they're both pile and
two but most people were saying angles
standing on the same arc angles
subtended by the same chord on the
circumference etc and the thing you are
missing wasn't they must be in the same
segment they are on the same segment but
almost no one said that they were and
that's kind of a critical part of the
reason you right we're not trying to be
you know really arbitrarily a narrow on
the wording if because if you don't have
that wedding there you've lost the point
of the reasoning okay so that was the
first problem that a lot of people
missed out you may have got lucky
depending on how good the rest of your
reasoning was and you might have still
got those two marks but um if the rest
of your reason he was flaky and you
didn't say that you would have lost
something just a brief thing here's my
diagram
the best responses drew a nice decent
diagram and they use the color in some
way right so that they could see the
triangles better and what the angle is
worth it you need it ok when you have a
look at this next part you can see I
mentioned this before here are my
subsidiary diagrams over here on the
right did you have to draw those no but
the people who did and the small number
of you did were much more successful at
being on set which sides correspond to
which ones right um some people when
they write out this relationship here
right instead of saying say a B on ck
you can see why I've got a B on ck right
what they might have said was uh
something like this a be whoops sorry a
be on BD okay now here's the thing if
you think about what the fractions are
if you match up a BB d and c kc d it's
actually an equivalent set of fractions
but it's just that it doesn't match the
reasoning because they're not
corresponding sides in different
triangles their sides in the same train
okay now I suppose the people who got
this wrong did it notice because they
didn't write the reason they didn't say
corresponding sides in similar triangles
they just said this on this is this on
this okay okay now in the previous part
you would have proved that there were
similar but you haven't said anything
about the properties of the sides okay
and when you have a look I've talked
about this before in extension to
sometimes we're like oh okay it's not
the emphasis of a question to talk about
similar triangles so just move on look
at Part C and tell me why I knew to do
this there's two reasons I knew look
carefully number one part one just says
sure that it's similar right so the
emphasis of part one is about the
similarity part to look at what's given
to you and then look at how many marks
are there right we're looking for the
reason if anyone can take the BD x AC
and we can take that result and just
shuffle algebra around I'm using that
fact and using part 1 okay but we're
looking for you to give us reason so
that's why there are two marks there
okay
in other cases where you're trying to
prove something else yeah sure say by
inspection if you like but this question
gave you an off course you weren't
supposed to do that okay all right once
you got there basically this question is
here entirely to sneak in the golden
ratio because the golden ratio is
freaking awesome okay it was tricky
because you're like wait a second part 3
says use part 2 but part two is about a
quadrilateral like Pentagon so you
needed to add in this extra construction
and see where the X's and the ones were
related you were lucky in that some of
you could be clever enough and it was
okay if you did this to bluff your way
through okay I think I can see which
parts of this are supposed to be X's and
which parts supposed to be ones in order
to generate the required quadratic okay
but yet you were supposed to draw a
proper dagger with a proper Pentagon are
you talking about sorry so let's let
number these lines so I've got line 1 2
3 which lie to you referring to I so I
wrote mine one yep managed to like I
something wrong numbers and I yeah and
get line two and then and then
everything was wrong from there
everything was wrong from there but was
it sufficient enough to have just buying
one to show that I was going to use
something from five to the answer is no
and I'll tell you why line one basically
is clendon equivalent to quoting a
formula right like quoting the question
rule or something like that okay now
coaching a rule is not what's being
assessed its understanding and properly
using that rule which is why you know we
can either reference sheet to show you
you remembered it cool but I need you to
show me that you know how to use it I'm
just saying why one is just repeating
what was said in part two I need to see
that you knew how to use it properly so
unfortunately not okay which is why I've
said her effective use of part two
because some people use part two but
incorrectly okay right I there are any
questions when we go to pardee
okay so let's have a look at this now
let's be clear you didn't have to draw
our diagram as awesome as mine but but
okay I i'm mainly drawing that for the
sake of you understanding like what does
it look like but also so you can see
that the worst thing that was done and
actually what was properly being
assessed to you was that let me just
briefly get rid of these guys when you
have a look at this and you're like oh
there's a volume and there are semi
circles okay a lot of people were doing
it like this right they had they had
their cross sections that looked and you
get the idea okay now this is what you
would get if you formed a volume from a
solid of revolution and what would I
have to rotate around to get this shape
the y equals x axis so you're going to
blick access we're seeing questions like
this before it can be done okay except
for the fact that that's not what this
question is about there is actually no
revolution happening at all so the
semicircle idea was kind of like a
curveball to see if you recognize that
when you have a look what I was trying
to see was have you oriented the
cross-sections correctly and if you drew
the cross-sections separate to your
diagram I couldn't I couldn't see that
you understood that now some of you
tried to get something like this right
like that and then you did you cross
section elsewhere it wasn't really
sufficient because I need to see them
related to each other okay so we put
those guys back it was a lot harder to
draw in a bleak looking diagram like the
one I have in the right hand side but
those of you who did that had it much
more it was it's a better diagram
basically I've put the one on the left
hand side there because it was perfectly
acceptable if you did that okay
I really need to see the cross section
together with the base at least once at
least once so I can see that you get how
they oriented together okay all right
now part two we unfortunately just got
hit by a series of my areas let's have a
look the first minor error was people
didn't have a half there they just went
to pie squared okay oops so you would
have got nine play on 280 because you've
gone all the way around instead of the
semicircle the second common era and I
made this error to when I was first
radius and then I was like wait what am
I done is are using the diameter instead
of the radius right that was a common
error because we're so used to using the
diameter and we forget to have it and
think I'll wait my form in the first
semicircles area requires the radius
okay so pretty much from there I think
we were okay you would have had a series
of carried forward errors okay if you
didn't yeah that's right ok now it's
worth pointing out and i said this for
previous exams as well you've probably
heard before if you make an error early
on for instance you might forget to
square right like you just do pi r pi d
or whatever instead of pi r squared
that's a single error but it
dramatically simplifies what you've done
later on you didn't have to muck around
with all of these guys here which we're
a disaster so you've made an error but
you've also simplified the question so
you basically lost two marks so this
happens in all kinds of contexts and
that's what happened here if you made
that kind of error okay as opposed to a
numerical error that didn't make the
question any easier